you guys I'm leavin playing Pete I've
been playing a hell boy owl boy
convenient segues we're gonna talk about
that this is a I'll hand it over to you
soon because you know much more about
the game than I do obviously you just
played it but kind of an indie game
that's been making the rounds getting
more visibility over the past weeks and
I know like people were kind of
clamoring for it over the past few
months tell me why what's what's good
about it huh well so it's interesting
stories this game has been in
development for a long time like a lot
of indie games by a small team and you
know throughout the years we've seen
little teaser videos like little
snippets of game play but nothing really
substantial and I think you know a lot
of the hyper in this game was built when
that sort of like retro aesthetic was
still kind of a new thing right like
this is a game of pixel art since we've
seen a lot of games come out with that
stuff while this game has still been in
development and I think a lot of the
anticipation lately has been like okay
elbow is finally coming out was all the
excitement you know in the previous
years you know did it have merit like is
this game more than just its aesthetic I
was kind of blown away by just how good
this game is I mean I you know as Eric
pointed out before the show like yeah I
have an affinity for this type of game
that's sort of art style and it's got
some twin-stick shooting stuff but what
I found was a game that really just goes
you know those things the pixel art is
special but the great things about the
game are more than just those few
qualities yeah how would you classify in
terms of genre if it can be is it kind
of the way you describe it is almost
like a hybrid of a couple things sort of
I mean it may look like a platformer in
some sense there are platforms but you
have free flight in this game so you're
there's only a couple scenes where you
know jumping to platforms like maybe
when your flight is taken away where it
actually is a platformer for the most
part the gameplay comprises of you know
exploring maps to sort of solve small
environmental puzzles and you it's sort
of like a twin stick shooter as well the
main character doesn't have a weapon he
has a dash but that's really only good
for stunning enemies you actually carry
one of the three allies with you when
you're flying and they have the weapons
so that that's kind of the brunt of the
gameplay but a holy crap man like I was
taken aback by this game
writing in the story which you know so
many games that that harken back to the
past they they try to be uplifting and
positive and kind of charming in a lot
of ways and alibi has those moments but
it dips beneath the surface and gets
real dark and sad as well and it's it's
incredible to see how the characters
change in the face of the [ __ ] that they
have to deal with can you talk about
this story much the premise without
spoiling anything or is that something
just going to completely fresh no I'm
not gonna explain it so you're basically
you're this boy owl
Otis you're mute and you're sort of you
know under the wing of yeah of you know
elder owls and they're sort of training
you in the face of a conflict that seems
to be growing pirates have been spotted
in the area and they're not really sure
what the Pirates are up to and so you're
sort of there at the moment when the
Pirates begin to invade this world and
you kind of have to fight back against
them initially it doesn't work and then
they start to do something bigger and so
the main game is you seeking them out
you know to stop this bigger event that
they're trying to create okay would it
be accurate or maybe not accurate but
either any I hate the phrase overuse now
but like Metroidvania aspects at all
none okay no I mean there is an upgrade
system in the game but the upgrades
mostly consist of you get canisters that
allow you to have more health
replenishments or you can upgrade the
weapons of your you know your allies but
there's only one upgrade step so you'll
you know you'll explore you'll find
coins you'll buy these upgrades but they
never unlock anything new at least that
I discovered and one point you get a
grapple that might take you you know
through a waterfall that you couldn't
fly through before but it's not the sort
of thing that defines this game I mean
they you know they even sort of strip
away any hope of a map in the beginning
because this character is like oh hey I
found a way to like you know map our our
world it might be useful and this guy is
like don't insult us for owls we never
forget we know where we're going and
true to form you never have a map in
this game you never really need it
there's a couple places where you have
to interact with things that aren't
really highlighted you know in their
one-off so like not being highlighted in
a specific way makes it seem like you
don't know where you're going
but once you've figured out you realize
okay that was just a small misstep and I
don't actually have to explore a lot I
really just need to just press onward
where the game you know is it
instructing me to go so you didn't
really get overwhelmed there lost too
much throughout no there was only like
two instances where I wasn't sure what
to do and with just a little bit of
poking and prodding around the
environment I realized okay that thing I
can interact with even though I didn't
realize it and focused yeah yeah you've
mentioned sorry there's like secret
areas or something too right like if you
spent the time to kind of I don't know
nothing's nothing substantial okay so
nothing worthwhile to go off the beaten
path to find no I I can't see why you
would like so just going along the main
path with some very very minor like
attention to like okay what's right
outside the main path I had enough coins
to buy everyone but the last upgrade and
the last upgrade you need every coin in
the game which I probably have just over
half I beat the game without it I don't
know what it does I don't feel like I'm
missing out and you mention like it's
coming on the tail of kind of an arrow
where we love this pixel art and hearken
back to it still looks really good but I
mean it's kind of past that phase where
there's a a trend right and now I don't
know I guess like this is it did that
long development time pay off in your
opinion like has it come at a time when
it might not be appreciated as much as
it should I mean I can definitely see
how some people might be sick of you
know looking at pixels because you know
nostalgia is a thing that really only
works initially once you you know you
play with some of these games that
remind you of the past maybe when you
finally beat it it fades into memory
because it's trying to remind you of
something that you really love even
though it's not any better than that
thing is trying to remind you of but al
boy's art I mean just to talk about that
alone like you know the the scene we're
looking at here most of the time the
camera is zoomed in about this much and
this is the resolution of the the pixel
art work but when you get into much
wider environments the camera pulls back
the pixels shrink and you're confronted
with these highly highly detailed
structures and and environments that
that really do showcase you know how how
much time was put into crafting this
game and that's also true in the
character animations you know there's
obviously stocky animations that
characters go through and having
discussions but there are so many scenes
where
they they break from that sort of
routine and they they have animations
you can tell we're crafted just for that
scene and it's just it's really
impressive how these you know pixelated
lo-fi characters are really brought to
life through just body language alone
people in the chat are mentioning like
it's probably like a stretch but
undertale just as far as like I'm this
minimalistic indie game that kind of
gets its story across in kind of cool
ways is there is there any merit to that
or is that just probably just stretching
because they're both you know like I
said smaller indie games from smaller
teams um I don't think having played
about half of undertale it delivers its
story in a different way it's much more
subversive this is a sort of
straightforward tale where characters
deal with conflict and grow as a result
and you know the the story isn't trying
to trick you it's it's it's pretty
honest about you know how it's playing
out I mean you were just along with the
party of characters as they are evolving
throughout this conflict cool so from
what I understand you're still like
working on your final review right yeah
it should be done today hopefully live
later tonight or tomorrow morning but
happy to say that this is an incredible
game and even though I had built up hype
for years
totally surpassed my hype which is rare
I think and it's available now on Steam
right it's available I if it's not right
now it's like in the next hour cool it's
coming out today
awesome well there you have it that is
our boy gaming development for a while
smaller indie game but gorgeous pixel
artwork uplifting story and from what
people around says pretty fun to play so
go check that out on Steam either now or
when it's up later today